hey y'all it's ender couch here and in
this tight tuesday video
it is the conclusion of the season one
tidy tuesday series
so i've officially done a full year of
tidy tuesday weekly content
and i figured for my last video for this
season i would end with a q a
so who am i um i think with my videos i
didn't really
explain a lot of my background so i just
wanted to go over like kind of like who
i am
um and why i why i did it the series so
i'm actually from iowa i'm from the
midwest and i went to isu my freshman
year
where i was planning on majoring in
computer science and
finance so i actually had a good amount
of programming classes in high school
where we were basically learning vba and
once i actually got to iowa state which
is pretty
known for their engineering and stats
programs
i found that i actually didn't really
enjoy pure programming i really enjoyed
mostly looking at
uh numbers and also dealing with um
stakeholders and doing a lot of meetings
and just kind of like talking with
people but also
doing some technical data work uh so i
switch into
mis which is management information
systems
and since isu is not only known for the
business school as opposed to university
iowa
i decided to transfer over to university
iowa my sophomore year
and then i just completed my college
years
uh through university iowa and graduated
in i think may 2020
so it's pretty interesting graduating um
with covid and stuff like that and
looking for a job i was probably one of
the hardest things i've done
uh in my 20s just working um
on a farm and applying to jobs during a
pretty competitive job market
but i managed to survive and i think it
really taught me a lot of like who i am
and what i wanted
to do in my career so what i really like
to do
when i'm not doing any coding or um our
data science research is i like to
actually do it i like to travel
a lot so usually i travel out of the
country
once every year i'm either with my
family or
just like with my brother unfortunately
with covid
um especially in 2020 i didn't do a lot
of traveling i went to colorado
um for a week but that was it but uh i
definitely enjoy a lot of traveling
um i did a study abroad in london for a
business
um for business school so i was in
london for a little bit
and i've been to like basically every
continent besides
antarctica which i actually really want
to go i need to figure out how to get
there
so one of my main hobbies is actually
not really data science
um i actually got into data was through
politics so basically when i was in high
school um
which was basically before which was
before the 2016 election
um i was heavily interested into
politics specifically um
elections so when i was taking a few
stats classes
at in high school um we kind of use
stats to look at
polls and understand like intuitively
how to like figure out what confidence
intervals are
um and i thought that was really cool so
after my stats class i
basically studied baltics for a decent
amount just in my free time
and i read a lot about um specifically
about elections
um so doing all that um basically made
me go into
like reading on a 538 which they're
known for their
modeling um and forecasting the election
so that got me
really in got that got me into looking
at data and trying to figure out how to
do my own modeling
which um i actually only knew excel and
java so i was based doing a lot of excel
work in politics and then
i decided that excel wasn't strong
enough so i simply googled you know how
can i manipulate data
um programmatically um at a higher rate
uh and then someone the first page told
me to look at r
so i looked at r basically uh my
sophomore year of college
uh and then that's basically how i
really got into r
and also i'm really into mma uh
throughout college i really got into
looking at mma and just like watching
ufc
uh with my brother and a few of my
friends so i watch ufc
fights probably every week when it's
available uh so usually on a saturday
i'll i'll throw it on to
i'll throw it on a ufc uh fight on one
of my monitors and then i'll do some
coding or some
um some work where i want to figure out
like what i want to do for my video
projects
so i wanted to use this slide to kind of
reflect on
this entire series i started this series
in february while
i was a senior in college and one of the
main reasons why i actually started the
series was
i was really bored uh from my last
semester
senior year because um basically at the
beginning of the
second semester for college in iowa it
gets very cold
they're basically stuck in your room and
for me since i was living
by myself i was kind of bored um so i
did a lot of r work
and then when i was actually doing my
capstone project with my um
with my other friends um they kept on
asking me like how did i get good at r
and i said like oh well i just kind of
practiced a little bit i did my own
little side projects that i found
interesting
and i thought it'd be kind of a good
idea to make a video
where they could kind of i could kind of
show my mindset
of me programming in r and that was one
of the main reasons why i want to start
the series because i was bored and
wanted to show my friends but also i
thought that there was kind of a
a misunderstanding of people's mindsets
when they're working on a project um
specifically like i think when
you're in college and you're looking for
a career
you watch a lot of like a day in the
life of a blank video so
for me i was watching a lot of like a
day in the life of a data scientist
video
and a lot of those videos are pretty
worthless
um because they don't really show them
doing anything it's mostly them on the
computer
so i wanted to make kind of a video just
showing someone
like what a person actually does when
they're analyzing data set
you know them saying like oh well i want
to use mutate to
put this another column so i can look at
the ratios of something
and i want to plot this out to see if
there's a relationship or maybe i want
to model this out to control for
something else
um so i wanted to make a video really
just showing
someone who doesn't know anything about
a topic
just looking into it and kind of
explaining the thought process
and lastly i think one of the reasons
why i really stuck with this project
uh was because i was still looking for a
job and i figured that
me doing a weekly video teaching
something
uh could kind of keep my technical
skills sharpened
while i was looking for a job because
you know i was just working on a farm
planting trees in the summer
and then i was just applying for jobs at
night so i didn't have a lot of time to
actually do a lot of programming
so i figured this series was a good way
to keep me sharp
so yeah that's basically why i started
this series um what i really enjoyed
about this series
was probably just the community um to be
honest i didn't really expect this
channel to get that big even though this
channel is very small it only has like a
thousand
subscribers but i really didn't envision
such a niche
topic you know like data science with r
just if we had the tidy verse i didn't
think that was a very
um anything a channel could really grow
into like a channel that had more than
100 subscribers to be honest
um so i was very um i was kind of
impressed by how many people were
commenting and how many people
i actually interacted with through this
series and i really enjoyed
like all the interactiveness i enjoyed
reading people's comments and them
asking me questions
of why i thought that i really enjoyed
it when people actually gave me
suggestions saying like oh
if you want to do this you try out this
package or hey it's actually faster to
do
this function because it's like
vectorized and stuff like that so i
really enjoyed the community aspect of
it
um i think one thing i would change is
that i wish i
figured out you know the structure of
the videos so for example the first
probably three or four
videos was me pretty much improving a
data set
and although i think an improv like
doing an improv for the data set is
interesting
uh it kind of constrains you in a way
where you can't really go over a lot of
complex
things so when i was going over like
embedding models
and lscm models and transfer learning
that wouldn't be a good
it would be very hard to do that um from
an improvisational standpoint
whereas if i actually have a data set i
want to show people and i want to show
this topic
it's easier for me to kind of plan it
out so i i kind of wish i
figured that out before i actually did
my series but
the series is pretty improvisational so
that's
i'm fine with having some of my videos
um not
be as focused as i would have would have
wanted it to be
so i just want to say that for this
future of the series um i am going to be
taking
a one month long break i think after
posting videos for
uh one year straight one time every week
and having a full-time job
i think it's for me it's time to just
take a break from the series
i'm kind of regrouping myself and i
don't want to make it
seem like i'm leaving this this channel
and i'm not going to make any videos
and in fact i'm actually going to try to
improve this channel and
improve the series so i'm going to
probably make some changes in the series
frequency too
i think adding a little bit more editing
and a little bit more polish
on these series um on these videos would
be better
for example a lot of these videos i just
kind of do a one take and i just go
through it
um i think adding some type of editing
some visuals um just to show some more
intuition
of things i want to show um additionally
i've had
a person reach out to me and talk about
like oh doing collaborations and having
more
um collaborative work and i think that
would be a good idea so
i want to basically add a little bit
more variety to these videos
and also a little bit more polished um
polished um
visuals um i don't want to go away
from the main point of this channel
which i think the main point of this
channel is
showing the raw code of these ideas so
when we're talking about image
classification
we actually go over the code to do image
classification so i want to keep that
but i want to also have you know a
little bit more higher level
more interesting visuals like statquest
does and code emporium does
while still remaining centered around
the code so i think adding that will
kind of help
a lot of new people who aren't as
familiar with the tidy verse and not
that familiar with r
can kind of understand these ideas from
a visual standpoint
and then they can kind of see how the
code interacts with each other
so now i'm actually going to go over the
questions um
that i received from my q a submission
form
i definitely didn't do all the questions
because some of the questions uh
didn't seem appropriate uh for this
video
not because they were inappropriate but
it's just because um they didn't really
go over a lot of things i think
were was necessary to be addressed in
this q a video so
if i also if i butcher your name i'm
really sorry um
i'm just terrible with names regardless
of your nationality so
um this first question is from our kumar
andrew i really like the videos that you
make what software do you use for
screencasting
i work for la unified uh school district
and have to make some
tutorial videos for my colleagues which
i can't upload to on youtube due to
student privacy issues
some folks are suggesting camtasia and
cam studio
any pointers would be appreciated so
what i actually use is
obs i think obs is probably the most
straightforward way
to actually um do screen screen
recordings
um for me i think i i just kind of
plugged in my webcam and plugged in my
microphone into my computer
started up obs and then kind of overlaid
a uh a little webcam uh
screen on the bottom right corner so
definitely look at obs
first because it's free and it's pretty
easy to customize so
um that would be pretty i think that
would be uh the first thing that you
should look at
so paul v says what does a typical day
look like at your job what is an example
of a project you're working on and what
are the deliverables
is the job what you expected it to be
and learn a lot from your videos thanks
and keep it up
so right now i'm a data scientist for a
transportation company and i think a
typical day look
is basically a combination of meetings
um and coding so
basically i think a typical day would be
me going to a
morning meeting kind of just showing
like what did you do yesterday
what are you gonna do today what
problems are you facing right now
and then after that you know you do a
bit of coding for me
for me i do a decent amount of coding
now just because i have really less
meetings i have some solid projects i
need to work on
and then probably in the afternoon you
might have to like message one of your
colleagues or like
a database person and say like oh hey
where's this table at
or why is this um field saying this
what does this date mean in the context
of a missing value
stuff like that so it's really a
combination of meetings presentations
and um coding so what is an example of a
project you're working on and what are
the deliverables
i don't think i can go over the projects
um explicitly but it's really a
combination of like
a typical classification problem um
some nlp um classification stuff some
like nlp
sentiment stuff um and a decent amount
of time series forecasting so
one of the things i was kind of
surprised about was the amount of
time series projects that i had to work
on especially since
time series stuff is not something i am
ex
that comfortable with but it's something
that i really kind of enjoy doing
and i think the job is a little bit um
it's
it's definitely more different than i
expected it to be so for example
um the position i have is way more full
stack than i expected to be so
we do a lot of deployment ourselves um
but for the actual stuff that i do is
typical data science stuff
so what do you like and dislike about
using r for general data science work
then so i think what i really like about
using
r is the internal stat functions
in r i think that's pretty easy and
additionally the tidy bursts
so one of the problems again with like
using
r versus python is python doesn't have a
great data visualization
besides like potly but with r all that
stuff is kind of
combined together with the tight reverse
so you can use ggplot
and deep wire together pretty easily um
i will say one thing i don't
like about r is that one it's pretty
hard
i mean you it's kind of hard to use
multiple cores with r
so that can slow down especially if
you're working with a lot of large data
and two it's kind of hard to do a lot of
deployment so like using docker with r
um it is definitely doable but the
amount of documentation
is way less compared to someone using
python
uh no tasks are noticed
angel hi andrew a huge thank you for
your videos in particular i've enjoyed
your focus on the titan models framework
and hope you keep on going uh it's been
super fun and
educational to see you work on on team
data occasionally as well
i would also love to hear more about
what practical skills you've acquired
and reflections you've had since
starting your job
is r still your main tool and what are
other important tools for up-and-coming
data scientists
how useful is tableau how much sql do
you think a data science needed data
scientist needs to know
i'm really excited about your plan to
integrate python in future videos as
well as much as i
are there seems to be a lot of more job
opportunities with python
give it a great work yeah so one of the
things i
think that you need to know with
you know using with more skill one of
the skills that is basically
underutilized
or under talked about as a data
scientist is one
understanding how um business processes
work
so the actual modeling is not the hard
part it's actually understanding like
why is this data here
how does this actual process work and
how can i
use it to model out you know a machine
learning model
for example like a lot of times you'll
see some problems where like
you have dates that are saying like 1900
or a date that says 9.99
those dates are not are are meaning
something but you actually need to
figure out like
why it's like that probably because you
know one day could mean like oh
it means that they haven't been assigned
something or maybe that they've
already churned out so being able to
understand
a business process or a process in a
business is very important for a data
scientist to know and
i think it's the most underrated thing
um being able to do you know
a lasso or elastic net or ridge
regression is not that important
compared to understanding a business
process
um is r still your main tool and what
are the other important tools for
up-and-coming data scientists
i think one of the most talked about
tool
is probably uh
uh was it the uh um
is definitely sql um people i
basically code in sql for half my coding
and then r for the rest
additionally alteryx isn't underutilized
or under talked about
software because most businesses will be
utilizing all tricks over rn
and python you know most business users
are using alteryx workflows
and it's something that a data scientist
needs to be cognizant of
and at least know the basics of a
workflow because
you know you can set up a lot of like
automations for your rsr
python scripts but most of the time
people will want
it in like some type of alteryx workflow
so how much sql do you think a data
science needs to know i think a data
scientist needs to know
basically like how to do you know
queries um pretty well so you know you
need to know the difference between like
having an aware
you need to know how to do you know some
simple joins you need to know the
difference between a left and a right
join
you know an inner join when you want to
use that um
definitely utilizing case statements is
a good thing but
actually doing like you know database
construction
and stuff like that is something that i
don't think is very important
but it definitely doesn't hurt to know
okay so uh mutual investor says i'm
looking to build or purchase a
workstation
or data science and model building give
me give my given my plan to utilize
tidying models heavily how much would
you recommend that i'll get most my
financial resources between process
cores memory and gpu
i think it's probably uh i definitely am
not someone who
knows a lot about you know um computer
architecture but i would probably say
spend most of money on the processing
core you know get an i7
um try to have it not as multi-core so
have more speed in in the individual
core over like eight
eight cores so like a faster four core
an eight core processor
um additionally if you're working with a
lot of large data
you might wanna increase your rams like
64 gigs um if you're going to do any
deep learning or computer vision
which is not really something tiny
models use uses you'll definitely want
to look at like an nvidia gpu but since
you're only using tidy models
i'll focus on you know a very fast four
core processor with like at least 32
gigs of ram
okay michael s says what is your
favorite thing about your job
so my favorite job of being a data
scientist is that i get to make plots
models and communicate findings um and
get paid for it so
i was always just making charts um
finding random datasets seeing what i
can do with it
you know i like making models and i like
i'm making
uh decisions using data so being able to
basically do all that stuff that
i enjoy doing while actually getting
paid for it is my favorite thing about
my job
you have a system of tracking habits or
how well you're sticking to your data
science
aims or probably goals um i guess
personally so on my own free time i
really don't like
setting a ton of goals for myself um i
really kind of just do like a random
walk where
i see something interesting i try it out
and if if i don't like it i'll just quit
um as for like professional goals
um i generally try to stick with like a
one three and five year plan
so for my one year goal i want to learn
some python
but how i learn python for that one year
goal is going to be different so
i'm not going to force myself to learn
numpy if i don't really like it you know
i'll switch with a pandas
or you know if i don't like psychic
learn uh when i'm learning
some uh some python i'm not gonna just
force myself to learn it but my one year
goal
would be still to learn a lot of python
um as for like
my actual job-wise how do we strict to
you know our deliverables
uh we definitely just do like scrum or
like agile practices
which i really enjoy so what is your
all-time favorite
mooc or online resource uh
definitely rsat's twitter uh i
i mean i don't think there's any single
um like book that i like reading or i
reread a lot but i think rsat's twitter
or specifically following
with the tidy verse um employees so like
max [ __ ]
julia silgi etc all of them provide
a ton of resources whether it's them
working on the packages and reading the
code
or reading the pull requests on issues
or them actually
like writing um textbooks that you can
read online so i think
our sets twitter and specifically the
tidy verse or rstudio
team is a fantastic online resource
any plans on creating your own course i
feel like you'd make a great teacher
i really appreciate um that you guys
like my teaching style
i really try to make it so you know you
don't have to have any past knowledge of
like stats or computer science
you just kind of have to figure out and
like read um some of like the r tidy
verse um framework
um that being said i have no plans on
creating my own course
uh but i do i think in the future like
for my profession i'd like to get into
teaching
um i think now since i'm a data
scientist which was actually one of my
five year goals is to become a data
scientist
is teaching i really like teaching so
one of the things i think would be
interesting is one like being a
like a teacher or teaching um like being
a professor in college and teaching
like data science in college but one of
the things i really would want to do
um is probably teach in a high school so
i think having a data science class in
high
high school would be super interesting
and i think would be
good for society as as a whole um and
that data science
in high school would be like how to
understand or interpret data right how
to read a chart
uh how to use data on what to look for
in data
um and just like being you know being
able to understand and read data or
being able to think analytically
um would be a great course in in high
school because
i think the age of you know the 21st
century
every every single profession has to use
data whether it's
excel i'm looking at you know averages
or means
or just doing actual like deep learning
it all requires data
so i think having a data illiterate
population
is an important step in society and i
think teaching that in high school
is a great way to kind of go with that
goal
do you think a master's degree in data
science is worth it or is it better to
study by yourself
uh that question was made by sebastian
and
i think it's a very complicated
question because on one hand i think
getting a specialized degree
in data science makes a lot of sense at
first however
i think masters are a lot of the time
a money grab and a master's degree in
data science
is just too early to know so if you want
to become a data scientist
and you have the option to do a master's
in data science
or statistics or computer science i
would
argue it's better to do the master's in
statistics or computer science or even
econ
um and being able to study data science
techniques
is pretty easy if you have a pretty
strong technical background
say in stats um research like psychology
econ or computer science so if you come
from like a mathematical background
maybe getting a master's in computer
science would be better
if you had come back from a computer
science background maybe getting a
master's
in statistics would be better if you
come from a research background
uh probably doing a massive computer
science would be easier
so for me i i definitely don't have a
master's degree
um and i mostly self tell myself a lot
like r
and stuff like that but i also you know
had a decent amount of technical
experience from just like talking to
professors
taking some stats classes and stuff like
that uh so i think it's actually easier
just or better to study by yourself
and get a master's in either stats or
computer science
uh okay joe hammo johamul r
from youtube um hey thanks again for all
your work i am a student in
economics in france i discovered our
lesson one year ago and your videos have
been really helpful to me
i'm watching them almost every week
since a few months ago now because even
though i don't usually have time to
practice
it opens a lot of doors to uh to what to
do and
or next the last exam video for example
is really great for that
again thank you about the question it
could be nice to know
more about your background either in
college or concerning programming for
example how long have you been using r
and if you're using other languages on a
daily basis
in france r is a r is getting big in
university
but it feels like python is the software
which is getting the big prize in
business companies
so my main background in college was the
uh bais or business analytics and
information systems
um but i had a pretty strong background
in programming so i knew vba
and i knew java um pretty well and then
i taught myself
our my sophomore year of college where i
was learning that
um specifically like doing like random
data analysis and random
charts so my first data set i ever used
uh
i ever looked at in r was the titanic's
data set
um and then i went on to do like a lot
of like nlp stuff and a lot of um
on charting um so that's how i learned r
um so i basically i know
i've been using rf for the past four
years but i really got good at r
probably my junior year i'm doing my
internship where
i had a lot of free time where i write a
decent amount of our textbooks
so one other language i really use on a
daily basis is definitely just sql
and that sequel isn't very complicated
it's mostly a bunch of like
you know selects with some filtering
um some like with statements and stuff
like that so
you just some sub queries some join so
nothing too crazy
um i think with regards to python
being like with regards to python being
used more in industry
and are being used in in education
i think that's kind of a problem right
now um i think especially the r that's
being taught in university isn't
the greatest r that can be taught so i
think
obviously teaching the titan first is
better for learners who are warning r
um but also i think if you can learn
r fairly well it's pretty simple to
transition to python
most of the people that i work with were
data scientists
they learned r a little bit in
university but they found that they
liked python better
so they taught themselves python each
language has their
own advantages i will say r has a better
community
so if you're doing a lot of like
self-teaching or you want to
read a lot of textbooks to learn r i
think r is a better resource at least
having a community standpoint
okay i don't know why i did that
transition so uh rogers says which are
the best place where are the best places
to learn data science on the internet
um i think probably the r studio blog is
the best
place to learn it so if there's any new
data science stuff that you want to look
at
the rstudio blog is great another good
resources
resource to look at for like
understanding a package is just looking
at
you know the github repo of the package
and specifically seeing if there's like
a
a nice little blog down page or like a
nice little vignette to show the
examples
but i'm definitely looking at github r
studios blog
um book down so any like book down um
page
is a good place to learn data science
uh corel says hi which books or sources
would you
suggest for one to learn more about
machine learning techniques
so the first book i read to learn about
data machine learning techniques was max
kuhn's applied predictive modeling which
i believe there is a textbook and
that's the textbook that really got me
into machine learning and understanding
the basics of it
another good book is statistical
rethinking um which is like uh which i
believe is a free version
like on columbia's website so definitely
like statistical rethinking and applied
particular modeling are
the go-to textbooks that i would
recommend to learn machine learning
uh ivan says can you give us a real-life
example of what kind of problems you
need to solve
in your data science job thanks so a lot
of the problems that i face
um at my company especially with working
in
data science and transportation is
understanding
how our drivers
react to the business so one of the
things that we want to make sure
is basically how can we ensure the best
quality of life
for our drivers who are our main um
main factor in driving revenue in profit
for the company
for example we don't want drivers to
leave we want them to continue working
for us
it's very hard to um train drivers so
hiring drivers
uh when we hire them there's a lot of
training that goes into it
so basically how can we prevent drivers
from
quitting how can we make sure it's their
life is
easy um so stuff like that where
you know it's whether it's looking at
like you know reviews that our drivers
gives
about different products you know
helping drivers um
helping get like helping drivers get
back home on time
and stuff like that so most of my job
basically relies on basically improving
quality of life
or um our drivers or our employees
um calling power says first off thanks
for the great content have you ever
dabbled
with bayesian methods in your data
science projects or slash free time
as a self-learned bayesian i find some
of the black box moments in
for example machine for example and
machine learning can be frustrating
i really miss the expressive way of
bayesian model and many of the data
science tools available
thoughts so i definitely think
um if you come from a stats background i
guess or if you
um really enjoy bayesian framework it
really is hard to get into these black
box
models especially because it can get
frustrating with understanding what's
going on
but i think a lot of times black box
models are easier to learn
uh with um beginners
as for me i do a decent amount of like
brms modeling
at my work uh because we actually care
more about
interpretability over you know black box
models
so i do a decent amount of like binomial
regression models and stuff like that
uh julia says what's your favorite
project that you've worked on during
your career or studies so far
so i think the project i'm most proud of
right now is the tidy tuesday project
i really enjoy um making videos and i'm
really proud of the community i created
even though it's very small i think it's
a very good community and all
all of the content made by my commenters
and subscribers
has been super productive and honestly
great uh creates a good discussion
um my favorite data science project is
probably
uh my sweet board project because i
think it
has the most use for my own work
specifically looking at
um text data and i really enjoy just
creating that because it's
to me it was a really cool thing to do
because i like looking at social media
data
i look looking at text data and i like
creating dashboards
but being able to combine all that stuff
together all together
is pretty cool um one of my favorite
products
that i worked on in my career
was probably a project centered around
assessing review quality
um i can't go too much into it but it
basically combined a lot of bayesian
methods
and nlp and topic modeling so i got to
basically combine you know a lot of nlp
work while also combining you know some
bayesian
analysis um and it is real
and it the actual product of it
combining you know the text analysis and
the bayesian methods
based analysis together create a really
cool dashboard
uh which i think the people at my work
will really enjoy
and um seems to be having pretty good
feedback so that's my favorite project
in my career um basically a review
analysis using
you know nlp and bayesian analysis
so golden graham says have you how have
you such
oh how have you saw two moon how do you
have such motivation to
do wait sorry uh
i'm sorry uh how do you how have you
such a motivate
your big organ how do you have
motivation in your regular work
and do it for free um thanks i've
learned some things with you
clinton you should also do a blog down
uh i think a blogger would be
interesting i i definitely need a little
bit more time to look at that
but i think the way i the reason why i
have so much motivation to do these
weekly videos
um is because i honestly guys have
covered um with covad i'm basically you
know
kind of stuck in my own house i can't
really do a lot um
so for me it's not too big of a deal but
i definitely
think i need a break from now for at
least a month to get my collect my
thoughts and you know
relax a little bit um i will say how i
actually create my videos
is i make them very spontaneously so
usually i i am planning that i want to
make a video
every week to be probably released on
monday and then have it
to be uploaded on monday and then to be
actually released on the tuesday
but the actual ideas come up usually
like on a saturday or a sunday night
and then i kind of just workshop it so i
i'll think about the idea
i'll find a data set that maybe matches
with it then i'll write it
and then i'll probably record and then i
record it on the monday
and and release it so generally i only
spent about two hours
so one hour thinking of the idea
workshopping it and the other hour
actually recording it so
while i'm gone um i would say check out
my github because i'll probably still
continue working on a few different
projects
um also watch other youtube channels so
three youtube channels that i really
like to watch that definitely do similar
content is david robinson i love david
robinson's videos
he was the one who really inspired me to
make some tuesday videos
um julia silgi makes fantastic videos
about tiny models
um and then code emporium i think code
emporium is just a fantastic data
science channel
um i think all this content is great it
really reflects
on like you know on a high level what
data scientists should be thinking about
i think david robson has you know the
most creative
r on programming that i've watched and
julia silvie just has a really good tiny
models videos because she
has a direct uh relationship developing
tiny models
i will also say i spelled check out
wrong but check out rsat's twitter
some people that i like to follow is dr
jacqueline
nolis or no noise and this she has
fantastic
r content in our memes um speaking of
memes um chelsea
parlot uh pelority um she's very famous
among like stats twitter and rsat's
twitter she has a fantastic uh twitter
page
tom mock or thomas mock has again
fantastic content he really uh helped
with like datetable
and nfl data and then lastly emily
robinson which
she also makes really good content she
also does a lot of she wrote a book on
data science careers and finally i want
to say thank you for watching all my
videos for
a year and i'll see you guys next week
and tidy on